COMMITTEE FOR MONDAY JUNE
HEREBY CALLED ORDER. PLEASE BE
ELEVENTH TWENTY EIGHTEEN IS
ADVISED ON AUDIO AND VIDEO
RECORDING OF TODAY'S PERCENTAGE
FEMALE. AND IS ALSO BEING
TELEVISED. AMENDED SECTOR PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. COOLEY CARE
CUNNINGHAM CARILLO
CERVANTES
FRIEDMAN.
HERE GRAYSON THEIR
MAYES SCARE NAZARIAN SALAS.
WALDRON.
SHOULD COME INTO A PANIC. BORN.
VERY GOOD.
PRESIDENT HE SAID HERE
CUNNINGHAM GOOD EFFORT. HERE.
MANY DOLLARS A.
AS LONG AS.
WE HAVE A. CONSENT AGENDA WE'RE
MAKING A ADJUSTMENT
SENATE AGENDA.
SP FOURTEEN TWENTY FOUR PAN HAS
APPEARED ON THE AGENDA. WAS
GOING TO GO FIRST TO THE ARTS
COMMITTEE THEN SHE DID IT.
BUT CONFIRM WHAT THE COMMITTEES
IT MAKES MORE SENSE TO FLIP THAT
ORDERED FINISHED ARTS WE'RE
GOING TO MAKE THAT ADJUSTMENT TO
ARKANSAS
SWITCHED THAT IS OUR MOTION ON
THE CONSENT AGENDA MOVED AS.
CHAIR.
BY MISTER SALAS SECOND
ENVIRONMENT COMMITTEES ON BAD
SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
COOLEY. AYE COOLEY AYE
CUNNINGHAM AYE CUNNINGHAM AYE
CARILLO. CARILLO AYE CERVANTES
FRIEDMAN GALLAGHER.
AYE GALLAGHER I GRAYSON. GRAYSON
AYE MAIENSCHEIN MAYES AYE NOSE
AREA SALAS.
SALAS AYE WALDRON AYE WALDRON
AYE.
THE MOTION IS PASSED IN THE